you
welcome to climb on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday you can ask
questions anytime on the platform and we
have Googlers on the standby to answer
them
I'm in-house Kazi developer advocate for
Google Data studio and I'm Matt Hamrick
developer program engineer for data
studio let's get started so data studio
is Google's business allene inclusions
and data visualization platform in this
presentation we'll cover what is data
studio who can and should use a studio
how can you connect your data in data
studio and how can you share the
dashboards that you create before we go
into a presentation let's try to see who
would be interested in using today's
studio maybe you're an analyst who wants
to monitor our internal business metrics
of a business or maybe you're a
developer who's working with a client
and from the solution your building
needs a dashboard built on top of it
maybe you're an executive who would like
to present results in the meeting for
maybe a quarterly results or maybe a
all-hands results or maybe you're a CTO
of an organization who would like to
provide additional value to your
customers or maybe you're a data
scientist who had just done some great
research and have some findings and
you'd like to publish these findings on
a blog post so that everyone can see
those and play around with the data or
maybe you're just owner of some data and
would like to visualize that in most of
these cases the solution that you need
to work with the visualization platform
would be to be scalable interactive cost
effective and high performing and all
these cases are go very well with data
studio because it is a visualization and
reporting platform that's completely
server serverless it runs on Google's
cloud you can build engaging reports and
dashboards in the platform you can
leverage team work that works and you
can use existing connectors and
templates and also data studio is
completely free to use you don't have to
pay anything to use it now let's see
what you can actually do look at we'll
have a look at a few examples so the
first one over here shows us some
website performance and this is a live -
word
you can see it's pulling in data from
Google Analytics account of the Google
merchandise store you can pick different
date ranges here you can pick user type
and this live dashboard shows different
kind of metrics that you can use to
evaluate even your own website we're
using the same template now let's have a
look at the second dashboard and this is
an economic dashboard which talks about
the economic freedom index of the world
over here on the left side you'll see
that there is an overall score
distribution and then there's a decision
of all the other scores that make up the
index and as you hover over each of the
data point it will show you the detailed
information about each data point
antivenin look at the last dashboard
this is of course a FIFA World Cup
leaderboard where you can see results of
different games of the FIFA World Cup
and how the whole game progressed if I
look at the live knockout bracket you
can see over here as the data loads of
the results of every match from the
round of 16 to the finals but these are
some examples of what you can do with
data studio the way the studio works is
that first you connect your data then
you analyze and visualize it and then
once you've built a dashboard you can
share it with other people so when
you're connecting your data the way you
connect your data industry is you use
connectors there are connectors
available that let you use data from
Google sheets or other cloud services
like bigquery obstacle out storage or
cloud spanner if you have on previous
data in maybe post recycle or my sickled
you can also bring them in furthermore
you can connect to other Google services
like YouTube analytics AdWords
double-click search console etc but
here's the problem
what if your data is not in any or any
of these sources what if your data is in
in some kind of maybe external website
or in a social platform or maybe it's
on-premise hidden behind a some kind of
authentication method what do you do
then that's where we have community
editors and Matt will talk more about it
hi thanks maha's
so community connectors are the solution
that we have in data studio that allows
to connect to your own data that's not
necessarily in Google so community
connectors is kind of three main points
to it it's built in app scripts which is
Google scripting platform that works
across all of the different Google Apps
it's low effort to develop you only need
to define a few functions and it has a
share and publish model that should
already be familiar to anyone who's used
drive so develop a connector you have
these three main methods that you have
to implement get config get schema and
get data get config the first one is
just a way that you can say these are
the configuration options that are going
to be necessary in order for my data to
actually be connected to get schema just
provides the fields that will be
necessary to say these are the fields
that make sense for my data source and
get data is the actual fetch to the data
source itself so this might be talking
to some sort of sequel database or can
alternatively just be making like a
simple HTTP call so I'm going to do a
quick demo showing the community
connector this one is for stack overflow
so what you'll do when you go into data
studio is you'll have the ability to
make a connector to any data source here
so I'm just going to search for stack
and you'll see here at the bottom we
have stack overflow questions that's the
one I want to use so I just click create
data source and that takes us to this
next page where we'll be be configuring
the connector so you can see that
there's kind of a few options here it
says which tag would I like to do how
many results do I want and what sort of
sort should it do so I'm going to use
the predefined tag of Google Data studio
and then I'm going to go ahead and I'm
going to do a results count of 22 and
I'm going to sort by votes you'll also
see here at the bottom that there's a
thing checked that says use report
template for new reports this is just
provided by the connectors creator and
it's basically a way to like get you
kick-started where once you have this
data source it will give you something
that looks good already
so we click connect and we see this
filled screen you'll see that there's
quite a few fields that are provided
from this this connector
yeah view no question counts links
activity
etc so I'm going to go ahead and create
a report here and this will take us back
into data studio so this is what minhas
was showing previously he was showing
pre-made dashboard this is kind of the
editor view that you would see for it so
you'll see here that eva all i had to do
was put in a couple of configuration
items and I already have a live
dashboard that's looking for sack over
overflow questions there we go so you
might be wondering what's actually going
on behind the scenes when I went through
all those actions so we kind of have
three main categories that happens with
this connector flow we have requests
that are actually made to your app
scripts connector code we have the data
studio interface and we have the user
interaction that would happen on the
interface itself so the first thing that
happens is the user selects the
connector in data studio that in my case
was when I was searching for the stack
overflow connector after that searched
and selected we just do a quick call to
get off type which is an additional
function you provide that just says what
sort of authentication or connector
needs if necessary we trigger an off low
in our case we had already authorized
that connector so that was unnecessary
so we kind of already completed the auth
flow the next thing that happens is a
call to get config and this is what
actually made it where we could see that
which configuration items were needed in
the case of stack overflow that was the
tag and the the sort options we show
that configuration interface and we let
the user complete the configuration and
then at that point make a call to their
get schema function and that was able
that was what was able to show us the
config fields on the next page we show
that field screen and the user can edit
those as necessary in our case we are
already happy with the fields that were
there and then we're just into data
studio at that point the user can add
any charts as necessary or in my case we
had a template that I already had the
charts created so it ditched did a get
data call and it brought in all the data
that we needed at this point data studio
just shows the chart with the data so
just a quick thing to mention we have a
community connector code lab that's live
right now you can see it at this link
below and I believe we will also be
sharing that in the chat this code lab
is just a great way to get started with
community connectors so that way you can
kind of see what would you actually need
to do to implement it for your own data
source
one thing worth mentioning is kind of
how you can share the community
connector so I mentioned earlier that
this is this is similar to how Drive
permissions work you can share with just
individual selected people you can share
with your organization organization
being a G suite account and you can also
share it with anyone with the link
anyone the link is a great way if you
want anyone to be able to use it all you
have to do is give them a link to your
connector and they'll be able to connect
to it we also have a new feature that we
launched this week called connector
direct links and direct links are
something that we're really excited
about it allows you as a connector
developer to give someone a link that's
personalized to them with the known
values that you can know that they'll
want ahead of time that also can
customize any templates so I'll show
that off right now through this link so
before when we went to the Stack
Overflow questions I had to type in all
of the fields that we needed and
actually we've had this happen a couple
of times before since this is still a
new feature currently it's behind a flag
we're gonna launch it in production
later this week so it's not working but
if this would have been working
correctly the Google data studio tag
would have been filled in along with the
result count in the sort so anyone could
just click the link and didn't have to
put into configuration yes I already
pump you so normally in this case it's
demo these fields up here would have
been filled in but since it isn't
actually live cried in production yet
there's just a small technical sure flub
there so one of the things that's nice
about the way we have the set up is
there's also a publishing model that's
friendly to individuals or companies for
individuals one of the easiest things
that they can do is they can just
publish this is an open source connector
this allows them to have kind of the the
maintenance cost to be put off where
we'll kind of handle making sure that
that's taken care of there's also the
ability to publish as a partner
maintained so this is saying you'll
maintain your own connector but you'll
also have all of the freedom to do any
sort of monetization schemes that make
sense for your use case all of these
guidelines are available on our
developer site and I believe that link
will also be shared in the chat below
regardless of choice this makes a simple
way where you'll be able to share your
community connector with anyone that
needs to see it
next slide we'll be going back to minhas
for our data studio can be used to
analyze your data but before that I just
like to draw the attention to all these
connectors that we have we're already
above 100 community connectors with over
500 data sources so we'd love to see you
use it so that's a lot of data sources
and a lot of connectors so Matt if I
want let's say I am a developing an
organization and I'd like to build a
connector what kind of experience or
expertise would I need really just any
simple JavaScript experience will do
since Apps scripts is just a Java Script
a Java Script that's run by Google
really all you need to do is implement
those couple of methods go through the
code lab and get started sure and let's
say if I'm building a connector to a
some kind of web api how much if I
already know about they say how much
time could it take to build such a
connector usually it doesn't take much
more than an hour to to get everything
totally sorted out including some tests
oh that's interesting
cool so we'll probably look forward to
some of our audiences building some
connectors let's hope so
so going back to the presentation after
you connect your data then you basically
analyze and visualize it we utilize it
in data studio we won't get to the
analyse part in details but we do have
an explore option where you can go in
and explore your data in a visual
interface sort of select and subset but
make a subset of the data that you're
you'd like to use create calculated
columns and then start visualizing it
and for the visualization we'd like to
show this nice dashboard that was built
like by click inside this sort of a meta
data so your dashboard that shows off
different types of types of charts in
data studio using a data studio
dashboard so as you can see here we have
a big number type chart bullet chart
door charts also pie charts bar column
paired column stacked bar line graphs
stacked area scatter plots maps and geo
pots and all these graphs are available
to use in data studio you can take your
data and if your data supports it then
you will use those charts now there are
some other examples we would like to
share our that uses these default charts
let's take a look at first the economy
this has some economic information we've
already shown this dashboard once that
shows the distribution of the world
equal freedom index by different
countries and there is another dashboard
which is the Google Analytics dashboard
that was created by the Google News
initiative team this is focused more
towards news websites and this is more
of an experience than a dashboard and
we'll show you what this means we'll
first search for the Google merchandise
store analytics data and as you select
it this data will fetch data from your
analytics account and populate the
entire dashboard and you can see that
this statute is right now loading the
data and as it loads the whole dashboard
will basically show the flow of your of
the visitors to your website and how
they convert into different measures and
that those numbers will show up and you
can read through the different text and
sort of the dash will explain what is
happening so you can easily use this to
do to create interactive infographics
and then we also have this very nice
dashboard that is that uses a committee
connector this dashboard is the Google
fit community connector and this was
created by datasource Rex and this most
likely has some dummy data populating
this but you can copy this dashboard and
use the Google fit comedy connector to
populate this using your data and only
you have access to - what are known also
lou to see it I mean intersect where you
can see you can track average weight
over last two weeks
average activity over last 28 days and
average steps taken over last 28 days
and this gives you a light nice overview
of what has been happening in your life
and lastly we have this other example
which shows IOT data now this is pulling
in data from a bit coy database and it
is pulling in data for different sensors
you can also if you have IOT data may be
in bakery may be in popsicle or may be
in some other sources you can pull those
in and visualize those IOT data indeed a
studio and share the results with other
people
now you're built you have connected to
your data you have visualized it but
maybe when you're visualizing it you're
missing some specific type of
visualization or the revelations that
are available in data studio doesn't
necessarily work for you for that we
have a new feature that is in Developer
Preview right now that is called
community peace what but this lets you
do is build your own visualization in
JavaScript and then you can bring that
into Data studio and we have the
documentation available in our developer
site it'll tell you how you can build
your own visualization and we also take
a look at a live example let's have a
look at the showcase and see what
different examples we have so let's say
we look at the Sunburst dashboard so
that if someone is trying to build a
visualization if they already know d3
and already can build a base how much
difficult but difficult easy to bring
that village mean to need us to do I
would say if you're already familiar
with the visualization library you're
looking to use it's probably 35 45
minutes for this one it's a little bit
simpler okay that's that's very
interesting so maybe we'll have more of
our audience bringing visualizations for
data that's up for that too so as you
can see this is a company this is a
JavaScript based visualization built in
d3 and that's being visualized indeed as
free right now and it'll work with other
data studio functions like filters if
you are using dropdowns or that will
work with this this is right now in
Developer Preview so if you'd like to
use this you can go to a developer site
and sign up for that it works with you
so you've connected to your data you can
analyze it and you visualize it but now
you'd like to share this there are
different sharing models available in
data studio
so first of all you can share the
reports using the G sweet or Reformation
so just the same way you would share
Docs slides you can similarly share
reports with other people you can share
them by user or across your organization
or anyone with a link and you can also
give people view access already Dax's if
if you give someone RBS they'll only be
able to view the dashboard and pair with
the controls on the dashboard but
they'll be able to change
in the dashboard but if you give them
edit access they can use the data
sources available in the dashboard and
create new charts and graphs now there's
a separate data model available for data
sources that you add as you remember
data sources are when you use connectors
to connect to specific data sets those
are added as data sources in data studio
data sources can also be shared with
users data sources can have viewer
screen shells or owner screen shows what
that means is if you create a data
source with owner screenshots and you
create the - you create a data source
and then you add that data source to a
dashboard anyone who views that
dashboard will see your data however if
you create the data source with viewer
screen shells and then you create a
dashboard with that whoever is viewing
the dashboard will see their data an
example of this would be Google an exact
word where you if you put in viewer
screen shows it'll be the same dashboard
but when you view it you will see you're
a house but when someone else views
views that they'll see their accounts in
the same dashboard data sources can also
be shared with view access or in Texas
and when you create it actual you can
also emit it as a report or infographic
on different websites we currently
support iframe base embeds and also
embed let's see two examples this first
one is I believe a blog post on the
Google cloud big data blog where there
was a we made a blog post on the big
Bitcoin blockchain data in bigquery and
as you can see here this is a normal
blog post but this dashboard is a
interactive data store dashboard that
has been embedded using iframe and the
second link that we have is another blog
post made on medium by one of the
developer advocates at Google and this
dashboard over here you visualize this
all the World Cup FIFA World Cup goals
so far and you can play around with the
data you can filter it it also changes
the links based on your selection and
you can view details on demand as you
hover over different data points so once
you've built a dashboard you can also
use it as a presentation instead of
using a
if you want to either giving a
presentation and if you want to show it
as your presentation aid you can show
the dashboard fullscreen and play around
with it use different filters you can
also in data studio you can use the
community collectors to build
push-button solutions what that means is
maybe the users you're trying to reach
New York no sequel maybe they don't know
about the database that you're using
maybe they don't own the schema maybe
they don't even know how to use data
studio or they have a question of time
what they would like to do is they'd
like to collect your data source provide
some configuration view their data and
then have a templated result so you can
do that using community characters what
you can do is you can create a community
character you can attach a template to
it and once the template has been your
nuts you can deploy the comedy connector
using a single link what will happen
then is your user will come in put in
click click on that link view the
configuration and they'll fill in the
configuration click connect and they'll
see a templated dashboard with their
data and that data will be created only
for them and they'll be able to edit it
they can share if they want or they can
just view it for themselves so let's see
an example of what we need so this is a
data set available in bigquery this is a
chrome user experience report that has
data for over 5 million different URLs
and it will contain data about timing
for first paint first contentful paint
Dom content loaded and unload and it'll
show the distribution of time for all
these websites you can further dig down
into the data using dimensions like
effective connection type like 4G 3G
device type a phone tablet or desktop or
which country the users are coming from
so all of this data is available in
bigquery if you go to the bigquery site
for this dashboard you can see that this
data is kept there by month now if
anyone wants to access is there they'll
have to go into bigquery run create
their own sequel and then run the sequel
and then they can access the data and if
they want to visualize it they can bring
the data into the studio using the
bigquery connector
that is the more longer way and if you
want to get finer control but if you
want if you're let's say the owner of
this data and you want to give a more
easier solution to your users what you
can do is create a community connector
and we've done that and we will show you
the example so after creating the gamma
T connector all you give to your users
is just this one URL so we click on this
URL and we'll go into later studio with
that connector selected and waiting for
configuration and Matt I believe we can
also add use this new feature to
pre-configured this configuration yes
this will be able to be pre-configured
as well also so we will add in a URL
that you put in Wikipedia and we'll
enable this parameter to be modified in
the report so we'll click connect allow
and the schema looks fine and we'll
create a click on create report so this
will fetch the data from the BQE
database and then create a light
connection and then it'll showcase that
data in this dashboard that is created
only for my user and I can edit this I
can also share this with other people
and as you can see we have different
pages available for this dashboard that
uses the data for which PDF now we have
three different pages and also view it
now this dashboard is created only
specifically for me so I can go ahead
and edit it and this will not edit the
template so I can go into the first page
and maybe I also want to see this data
for a separate website so as you can see
this is a completely drag-and-drop
interface where I can make different
kind of changes I move this one move
this one to the left and we'll try to do
quickly make some new changes to this so
this will pick all the elements on the
dashboard that can be configured to copy
paste them move them to the side and
let's say we will change the parameter
to have a different website so maybe we
will look at
google.com so as you can see this is
completely configurable by the dashboard
and as we type in the new configuration
we have this side-by-side comparison for
the website partials of these two
websites and once I've done that I can
go in and I can share this report with
other people I can share this by link
and publish this on the website I can
share this with specific people within
my organization or I can even share this
across my organization so this is how
you can build a completely push-button
solution using communicators in data
studio
so to recap data studio is Google's
free business intelligence and reporting
platform you can connect to any data
source and make any visualizations that
you want in data studio and you can
share your visualizations with others in
different ways if you are trying to get
know more about data studio you can
build a dashboard by going into it'll do
the data so your Google calm if you want
to see more examples of dashboards built
in data studio you can go to data street
at google.com slash gallery this has
templates from our from our users and
different partners you can also have a
look at the community connector gallery
by going to W data studio at google.com
slash data you can get support by going
to support the Google Chrome slash data
studio if you are more into developing
solutions may be committing actors or
committee bees you can go into a
developer site which is available at
developers.google.com slash data studio
we also have a open source repository
available which has examples of
different code and you can go there by
github going to github.com / google data
studio and if you build something cool
maybe a an awesome dashboard maybe a
connector maybe this share that with us
by using the hashtag grew data studio
and now stay tuned stay tuned for live
Q&A we'll be back in less than a minute
you
welcome back to the Q&A session it looks
like we have a few questions from our
audience so the first question is can we
integrate graphs and reports created
using data studio directly with web
applications and it also asks about real
time reports I'll go ahead and take this
one sure so we can integrate graphs and
reports and data studio directly in the
web apps we kind of showed off a few
examples of that there was the blog post
that minhas showed those links should be
available as well
real-time reports aren't currently
supported in terms of like updating as
they go but if you just click the
refresh button it will always make the
data live again
so I'm assuming that we don't support
streaming data yet but can manually so
that yeah that's correct
there's no streaming data yet but you
can go ahead and just click the refresh
button and get up-to-date data that way
maybe we can also show the developer
page on how we can integrate different
reports in web pages so we have a page
for that and if we go in quickly
all right so we'll bring that up later
the second question is what are the
weight data studio to create simple
reports from databases such as my sequel
where stored procedures so if you
already have a stored procedure in my
sequel and if you have a view based on
that you can simply connect to MySQL
using the bicycle connector and then
connect to that view currently we don't
support passing in parameters from data
studio to that store procedure but
that's something we're looking into and
might be supported in the future but if
you have a view that uses the my see my
sequel store procedure and doesn't
require a parameter input then you can
just use that view third question is how
does one stop data studio reports from
running queries in the background so
datastore doesn't really run queries in
the background there are several times
will it run queries first is that if it
underst
if it knows that there are certain
queries it can made beforehand that will
speed up your report then even before
you open the report you do sort of
prefetch some queries and
store them the next time you open the
report it won't run the query it will
just fetch from the cache when you are
building a report every time you add a
component or every time you edit a
database that needs that request status
for you to get new data then it will fit
you can create a new query and then pull
that data in if you're viewing a
dashboard and the results are already in
the cache then it won't hit it will run
the crater will just fetch the data from
the cache if you manual if you're the
owner of the dashboard and if you
manually refresh the data then it will
run the query again if you are having
issues with multiple queries running
let's say if you're connecting to a
bigquery data set and if you're getting
a lot of queries one thing you could do
is maybe you can create a community
connector and set up your own caching
layer you can cache to fibers you can
cache to cloud sequel and then you can
set up logic where the first time that
data is being pulled it will pull from
bigquery and then cache it in the middle
layer and then every the following times
the query is run it will fetch from that
cache and that will significantly save
on your credit costs the fourth question
we have is can one connect Google Cloud
datastore to Google Data studio I'll go
ahead and take this one so the short
answer is yes and the slightly longer
answer is not right now so the the
reason the answer is yes is because you
can make a community connector that
connects to clout a Google Cloud
datastore I don't think we currently
have a first-party connector to Google
Cloud datastore but that would be a
great one to put so if somebody is
struck by inspiration that would be a
good one to make and then go ahead and
give us a pull request on our github
repo and the last question we have is
can one export two sheets emilynics book
report two sheets
you can't export the whole report like
if you have let's say ten pasted
dashboard where each page has five or
six elements
you can't export the whole thing as a
whole but what you can do is if on a
dashboard if you have different elements
if you hover over an element there'll be
a small icon then come up on the top
right and if you click on it you'll be
able to export the underlying data or
that element to your sheet so if you
click export to
whatever data is was used to create that
report or create this one element will
get export it into a sheet where you can
use that data and then create your own
chart or graph in sheet or maybe even
add additional data to it and that is
all that that's all the Q&A we have for
now thanks for joining us and stay tuned
for the next session see chat digital
transformation for non digital natives